let me just listen to my block
[Music]
hahaha
lights up for washington heights up at
the break a day i wake up and i got this
little punk i gotta chase away
pop the break at the crack of dawn sing
while i wipe down the awning
hey y'all good morning ice cold pita
cherry strawberry and just for today i
got my day
oh yes
you probably never heard my name reports
of my fame are greatly exaggerated
exacerbated by the fact that my syntax
is highly complicated cause i immigrated
from the single greatest little place in
the caribbean
dominican republic i love it jesus i'm
jealous of it and beyond that ever since
my folks passed on i haven't gone back
god damn i gotta get on then oh
the milk is going bad hold up just a
second why is everything in this fridge
warm and tepid
i better step it up and fight the heat
cause i'm not making any profit if the
coffee isn't light and sweet
abuela my fridge bro
try my mother's old recipe one can of
condensed milk
nice oh hey your lottery ticket
that was abuela she's not really my
abuela but she practically raised me
this corner is her escuela now
you probably thinking i'm up shit's
creepy i've never been north of 96th
street
well you must take the a train
even farther than harlem to northern
manhattan and maintain
get off at 181st and take the escalator
i hope you're writing this down i'm
gonna test you later
i'm getting tested times are tough on
this bodega two months ago somebody
bought ortega's our neighbors started
packing up and picking up another sister
rest went up it's gotten mad expensive
but we live with just enough
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rosario he runs the cab company he
struggles in the barrio
see his daughter nina's off at college
to wishing his mask thief so he can't
sleep
everything he get is mad [ __ ] good
[Music]
morning
okay must be a lucky day gotta be
oh my god you're so excited i mean i
flew in at 3am last night sweet
[Music]
it smells like one of those trees that
[Music]
sunny you're late chillax
you know you love me me and my cousin
running just another dime a dozen mom
and pop stop and shout and oh my god
it's got it
like my man cole porter said people come
crew for a few
cold waters and the lottery ticket just
a part of the routine
everybody's got a job everybody's got a
dream they gossip it's nice if my coffee
is smirk the first shop
is people hop to work
169 i got it you want a box of condoms
what kind that's two quarters two
quarter orders
the new york times you need a bag for
that the taxes added once you get some
practice at it you do rapid mathematics
automatically selling maxi pads fuzzy
dice with taxicabs
practically everybody's stressed yes but
they press through the mess bounce
checks and wonder what's next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
but guess what what still ain't got no
skills
[Music]
ain't got no no no
[Music]
it's not reflected in my
[Music]
[Music]
well your coffee's on the house
[Music]
[Music]
is and you're stuck to this corner like
a street light
yeah i'm a street light choking on the
heat the world spins around while i'm
frozen to my seat
the people that i know i'll keep on
rolling down the street but every day is
different so i'm switching up the beach
because my parents came with nothing
they got a little more ashore with paul
but yo at least we got the star
and it's all about the legacy they left
with me it's destiny and one day i'll be
on the beach with sonny writing checks
to meet my house
we came to work and to live and we got a
lot it reminds me that
i came from
is
[Applause]
every day every day
life and washington heights
you